Film Courage: Continuing on with advice for the 20
something-year-old writers that we get
feedback from I think you mentioned that
you went to see the writer Jorge Luis
Borges speak? LA4hire's Wendy Kram: Yes. Film Courage: And that he said I'm
finally getting better and it was
80-some yes right no cuz this is
something that happens a lot of writers
will say well when will it be ready when
will it be ready what or it's ready it's
ready and I have a client who I love
dearly and we work very closely together
and I many many drafts ago she said okay
this is it this is the final draft and
I'm like I would love her to be the
final draft I don't want it's not late
and I mean I do with consulting but it's
not like I want my biggest baileywick if
you will or heyday is to have a really
strong script that I can take out to the
market and get set up with a production
company studio Network etc and so I'm
reading it and she one of the things we
had changed the location from overseas
to New York and we changed one of the
characters from an Italian to a New York
Italian and she changed his name so I
think he was Giovanni and then he became
Luca so when I was reading that script
the character she kept she kept going
back and forth with the name and that's
just a very simple fix but you know
here's someone saying it's final and I
wanted to be final and it wasn't you
know a hundred percent perfect yet just
even on a very cosmetic level so the
notion of and when you brought up jorge
luis borges that i was in college and he
came to our campus and spoke and he was
in his I think he was about 82 and he
was going blind and he said Here I am
and then going blind I'm 82 and I feel
like I am just now getting good at my
craft and here was a man who received
some of the high
literary honors you can get and it was
inspiring and when I see younger writers
saying you know well it it's done it or
it's good enough for it and any writer
at any age can really say that I feel
like any time I've watched on some of
the talk-show interviews with
best-selling book authors amazing
directors screenwriters very often when
they speak now they say it's taken them
seven years so I feel like and when I
see someone like bore Hayes speak the
way he did if people who are such
masters it's taking them like seven
years or more or in the case of bore
case a lifetime to just feel like he's
getting good then we need to relish
enjoy soak up the process of continuing
to get better and better and better so
that's and I I mean anyone we greatly
respect whether today if it's Aaron
Sorkin or Jason Reitman they all say
that you know they go through multiple I
mean reitman I think it's like gone
through 30 40 drafts on some of his
projects and with the Aaron Sorkin I
don't remember how many like he does but
I also did hear him say once that it
takes him it takes him anywhere from a
year to 18 months to deliver a first
draft he's turning over and over the
characters and so I feel like if these
great masters who really have excelled
in their fields in their craft if it
takes them so long why do we think that
if we're just starting out that we
should be able to do it sooner
and I'm offer if it can happen soon
great but the process is the process
right and Jason is of a generation where
they want things faster yes so that
that's very telling in that sense
because I feel like now everything's so
sped up right and instantaneous that
it heightens all that you know here on
Twitter and see all this stuff about
this person's just been discovered but
we don't realize we don't realize and
I've heard also with some great writers
being interviewed you know people say oh
they just wrote it one or two drafts and
then when you hear them speak they say
that it was a they did multiple drafts I
just feel like basically there really
aren't shortcuts I do think there's an
anomaly maybe someone can write
something and it just everything's
aligned and the muse and the ability and
it just flows out of you and I think
that can't happen but it really is an
anomaly most of the time they're things
require more and more refinement and
craft it kind of goes back to what you
said earlier about the female showrunner
who's achieved great success but she
says people want the outcome but they
probably wouldn't want to do all the
hours and and all the probably late
nights behind a computer stressing over
some little deal yeah yeah and I think
that's a huge thing people don't see
some of that work that goes true and and
they just want the faster around and
it's human nature nobody want to have to
put it exactly but that's true
you